The high-water mark may already be behind
them, but the danger has far from subsided
on Sulawesi Island.
At least 3000 people were forced to leave
their homes as rivers burst their banks and
hillsides gave way under the heavy rains.
Flooding is hardly a rarity here during Monsoon
season.
But still residents say they were caught unaware.
The water started to rise here but then suddenly
a nearby river burst its banks.
After 10 minutes the water was already 1.5
metres high.
We didn't expect this at all.
Emergency shelters have been erected in local
mosques.
The military has been deployed throughout
the island.
Their first challenge: keeping evacuees warm
and fed.
They're starving there, kids asking for milks
and food.
It is hard to get there.
Rescuers continue to pull people from the
water throughout the island.
However with dozens missing and many villages
still underwater they warn that the number
of the dead will continue to rise.